I know that this may seem self-important
to some but there have been enough myths
out there and people have asked me
repeatedly I get I'll get Twitter at
messages I'll get emails is this true so
we wanted to take this opportunity to
and it's not really just about me but by
proxy people who work on the show so
here are the top five myths that some of
you may believe about me which aren't
true myth number one that I am a Nazi
and or extreme all right now I know
Nazis are different from all right just
like white nationalists and white
supremacists so like we said I find it
funny when Donald Trump condemned white
supremacist and the white nationalists
got offended
I thought you two are different things
bring up the screen grabs so you can see
these somewhere you can find fake quotes
you can find me with fake swastika
tattoos by the way yeah David Duke
himself lied about me I think even
edited together phone clips or someone
did to try to make it sound like I
endorsed him yeah the owner because they
got so mad that I didn't support their
white nationalist movement but they went
out so you know what we can actually
hurt we can try and hurt Crowder by
making him seem super extreme Wow so
it's not true and the only reason that
rumor started being spread is because of
myth number two that I'm Jewish what
happened you can read the comments read
the comments the anti-semitic comic
people who thought it was Jewish so
here's what what happened it started a
long time ago but it started with me
just it and I don't shy away from this I
support the right to Israel the right
for Israel to exist at the end of the
day Israel has recognized that
Palestinians have a right to a state on
the flip side Palestinian leaders
believe that the State of Israel and
Jews have no right to exist period and
if you support these leaders and their
nations so do you do you like looking at
that white background there in the
future
I know there's no producer so what would
happen in supporting Israel these people
he's an actual race actual actual white
supremacist actual neo-nazis got really
mad and started sending these threats
you know he's anti-semitic memes
pictures mean a gas chamber this
everybody thought that they would do to
ben shapiro yeah and then someone said
hey hey actually um he's he's not Jewish
they said shoot all right I know we can
be more damaging by making him out to be
one of us because everyone everyone
hates us so we'll make him seem like one
of us a neo-nazi and that's where you
get two myths number one myth number
three that I am an evolution denier /
flat earther you can see these again in
the comments section people have written
about it and message boards and articles
this one is pretty simple no this is
they say you're a Christian conservative
and sort of try and paint you as some
radically ideological anti science
zealot they go you're a flat earther
you're an evolution denier and neither
of which are true which can't be
substantiated but it's been allowed to
go unchecked by atheists and
pseudo-scientists on YouTube and of
course even in the media before YouTube
for a long time so people to leave it
and say oh he's a Christian he must be
the anti science people myth number four
that I am anti-pot more specifically
that I'm anti pot legalization that I
don't that I'm you know how can you be a
conservative how can you be a consistent
constitutionalist and still support this
idea of prohibition I've openly said
repeatedly let me clarify my position
and then point to the tale of the tape
so you know that it hasn't changed
because I know a lot of you don't watch
a 30 minute video I don't care if states
legalize marijuana matter of fact I'm
more Liberty I don't care if they
legalize crack or heroin if they want to
I don't care if you personally smoke
marijuana or do heroin in your own house
I'm fine with it
I'm fine with the actual medicinal uses
there are drugs out there compounds that
are derivatives from marijuana most of
them don't work a couple do I know
someone who takes one of the the
compounds for nausea after chemotherapy
I'm totally fine with that so I'm okay
with legalization I think it's a state
issue I'm okay with recreational use if
your state wants to do it I'm okay with
acknowledging some of the medical uses
of marijuana which to this day as it
relates to double-blind
placebo-controlled clinical trials are
relatively few my only issue is when
people lie about it when people say it
cures cancer when people say or make
unsubstantiated medical claims when they
say big pharma is trying to suppress it
or they say oh it'll reduce crime if you
legalize it it'll reduce a you know
drinking and driving accidents if you if
you legalize marijuana these these these
statements don't bear out so I'm fine
with all of
I just don't like it when people act as
though it's this benign substance which
comes with no side effects and by the
way it cures every disease known to man
for consistency in the video I didn't
say the government should be able to
outlaw pot in every state as a matter of
fact I take the libertarian stance if
pots want to legalize it fine and that's
what I wanted to be clear I don't care I
think people should be able to smoke pot
I support CBD I support words
medicinally useful I don't hate pot okay
I couldn't care less if you want to
smoke pot if States want to legalize pot
by the way that culminated an argument
about me being an teapot for about five
hours so I hope I've clarified that I'm
an anti pot fascist myth number five
this one's really popular we all get
this that I'm a climate scientist and I
are oh you're a climate change denier we
can't trust science you know what this
is this is this stems from a video that
I released a long time ago who are you
that's me to create a video debunking
climate change you're no atmospheric
scientist do you think about that is
neither are you neither is this guy my
purpose here is not at all to pretend to
be a scientist but to get you the viewer
to think about real science versus media
hype okay so even before that video I
made my my stance pretty clear in
multiple interviews so let's let's go to
the tale of it before that video even
with Dave Rubin do I think that the
climate is changing
yes is it possible that there's manmade
climate change maybe will that have
catastrophic results that we can't prove
that yet okay so let me reiterate this
climate change denier do I think the
climate is changing yes could humans be
contributing yes could they be
contributing a civic significant amount
sure what I have an issue with is the
predictions which cannot be verified
which will be catastrophic imminent and
we need to take action right now through
surprise government policies whether
it's the Kyoto Protocol when I was in
Cancun and I saw Ted Turner promote the
one-child policy which is why you have a
bunch of Chinese people drowning girls
and bathtubs or now it's the Paris
Accord which would [ __ ] first which
would
crippled actually third-world people it
would kill kill numerous countless
third-world human beings and [ __ ]
economies that are actually benefiting
from technology and of course hurt
economies that need to eventually
benefit from technology my issue is with
the cultural myths the cultural fault
falsehoods that people believe like the
polar bears going extinct that's not
true let the idea that all the ice caps
are melting that's not true some are
melting some are growing these are the
issues that I have a problem with
particularly as it always goes back to
government intervention when so many
predictions have been proven verifiably
false and you don't believe me go watch
an inconvenient truth to Al Gore if he
would be doing a victory lap if all the
predictions he made and the first one
were true
instead he moves on to being from the
media vilified me well yeah but what
about the money use in Florida would be
gone yeah so that's it and then you're a
climate change denier you tell me what
is more reasonable saying yep climate
change is absolute human beings are the
main cause of it and Ted Turner's right
that we need to kill our kids except for
one now by the way this sounds like it's
true it's not just like the lgbtq qqa
AIP number two people used to say to
straw man it's not this is where we are
if the left has their way if you look at
the Kyoto Protocol which was a precursor
if you look at the Paris Accord it is so
radically far left that you would think
it's a straw man it's not it is anti
human it is anti technology and it could
put human beings in the dark ages
that is my issue with climate change
alarmism does that sound like science
denial hey you like this video subscribe
by clicking the button that says
subscribe if not there's a strong chance
that you're an armenian genocide denier
well in quake i think you know what i'm
talking about but i don't over there if
this isn't the channel for you i'm sure
you'll find something there that you
deem very insightful and informative
also i request that you come back here
afterward and immediately leave a
negative comment because we read those
and those affect our lives directly we
care about them because we care about
you